[Music]
the cloud sales role has been such an
amazing journey it's just really
exciting what we get to do every day we
talk with all different kinds of
customers the role gives you quite a lot
of freedom
the ultimate goal isn't just revenue but
is actually customer success you know
we're out reaching you're trying to
break new accounts but you're also
dealing with accounts that are already
using Google cloud platform and and G
suite and asking them hey how's it going
you know providing that white glove
treatment to really make sure they have
the best experience with Google my
favorite example of that is Pokemon gun
they were able to go from zero at launch
to being bigger than Twitter in five
days entirely on Google cloud someone
described it to me our role in sales as
being like selling guitars to rock stars
you can really feel like you're a part
of something special we're a provider
that's I mean for the people we're
working directly with our customers that
are using it and getting the most out of
what we provide I think the folks we're
looking for have to be passionate driven
smart we look for people that are
connected that want to work as a team
right this is a team play it's a little
cheesy but the best part of the role is
unquestionably the team being able to
work so closely with Account Executives
who are the best of the best in its
enterprise sales has been a wonderful
learning opportunity and being able to
have front-row seats
to all the product development and
innovation that's going on a Google
cloud is amazing I think the future is
infinite when you think about how
connected this world is becoming we talk
about adding devices into that as well
the big classification around Internet
of Things the potential is infinite and
this platform that we call cloud
actually provides the underpinning of
the foundation on how these companies
will actually deliver those services
we're just now offering it to the public
you know it's the same infrastructure
we've been using internally for you know
since the beginning of Google but
customers are excited about it they're
excited about the products we're talking
to them about the solutions we're
talking about
if you want to fundamentally transform
and change what we're doing and how
technology is consumed in today's
marketplace this is a place to be
[Music]